now my original plan for this xbox
sponsored episode was to give you five
awesome moments from the 2013 Tomb
Raider reboot but I realized there are
so many epic and batshit crazy moments
from the entire franchise I figured I'd
give you five of those
now I was five years old when the first
Tomb Raider came out so you'll have to
excuse my lack of first-hand experience
my first experience with Tomb Raider was
getting mauled by Tigers in Tomb a
tattoo and then handing control back
over to my dad but did you know that
Tomb Raider has dinosaurs I sure as hell
didn't the wildlife in Tomb Raider one
is pretty run-of-the-mill albeit super
aggressive that is right up until you
mosey on into the Lost Valley and
stumble upon a [ __ ] t-rex apart from
being scared out of your skin that this
dude is a massive bullet sponge so
expect to get a bit very dead on your
first try
while the early Tomb Raider games
established the legacy of the powerful
gun-toting adventurer that is Lara Croft
it was the reboot that made her
relatable and human particularly during
her first kill you may sometimes wonder
how your gaming protagonist stakes so
smoothly to a life of serial murders
however narrative Lee justified but
Crystal Dynamics wanted the transition
to be a little more meaningful from this
Croft
after being shipwrecked and losing her
friends Lara is cornered into a
kill-or-be-killed scenario and she
doesn't take it lightly
all right so very soon afterwards she
doesn't think to mind firing arrows
through her foes brains but the first
time it happens is gritty and emotional
the moment where she fires off the
pistol is gory slow and brutal and it's
a very important turning point for our
heroine where she learns what she needs
to do to survive if you've ever played
the Tomb Raider game before chances are
you know that at a certain point it just
gets weird let's like Uncharted and
Indiana Jones at some point it trades in
its when it's a male gunman and forest
fauna figure for Supernatural such a
moment occurs in Tomb Raider 3 when you
go up against a massive freak spider
with a person face at the end of the
game I don't want to spoil how this
happens but the fact that it does is
apparently related to human evolution
massively speeding up if this is what
we're going to evolve into I'm happy to
leave the future where it is when I was
a kid I used to have Buffy esque dreams
where I'd save all my school friends
from various villains the plot in the
2013 to
ready to reboot where all of your pals
are trapped and in immediate danger and
it's up to you to save them
makes you feel super badass and
completely encapsulates that feelings
your friends all whoop and Cheer
literally call you about us and then
rely on you to help save their hides
which of course you do because you're
Lara [ __ ] Croft this is one of those
quintessential moments where your old
friends begin to see you not simply as a
bookish archeologist but as a
resourceful and tough problem Sylva your
friends yell motivating remarks to these
souls the light the environmental puzzle
to free them and share with every
success it's very cool and you certainly
feel like a hero traversing the
exploding ruin and saving the day now
for this last one I am putting a
disclaimer that you are gonna see a clip
from the very end of the Tomb Raider
reboot so if you haven't finished it yet
to be warned I won't tell you anything
about the final boss battle or what you
end up facing when all the chips are
down but there is an unbelievably cool
moment where Lara is having a power
struggle with the final big bag he
smacks her in the face she shoots him in
the shoulder and then proceeds to finish
him off in what might be the perfect way
for Crystal Dynamics to event at the
game after using just one weapon of
choice for the entire game Lara picks up
another pistol and dual wields them to
finish him off just like old-school Lara
would do Oh more accurately how future
Lara will do those are some of my
favorite Tomb Raider moments but let me
know what yours have been down in that
comment section I will catch you again
next week
you